[Music]
yep
Sedona just wilderness area it's too
crazy Cowboys I don't know where exactly
we're going but we've been hiking for a
couple hours
[Music]
just got it incredible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so I was going to make dinner see
there's my kale however my water will
not go down the sink so I'm gonna try to
figure it out I have no idea what I'm
doing but just to give you an idea I'm
guessing that something is blocking it
I don't really know so yeah that's the
situation also my hair is looking super
fly right now but I'm gonna try to
figure this out on my own very exciting
night in Saturday night woo stoked it's
a little update this thing just popped
off and it looks really gross so I'm
just gonna clean it out hopefully clean
out up there
you know dunks also really gross and
hopefully that will help I cleaned it
out there was some macaroni noodles that
got down there so that was kind of gross
and yeah just some other grimy stuff but
I was mostly concerned about
reassembling it and putting it back on
but I just did that and a turn on the
water and it's fine so far anyway
oh good ok so actually that didn't fix
the problem there seems to be a kink and
that looks suspiciously like a macaroni
noodle I'm gonna try using this to pinch
the pipe and hopefully release that
macaroni noodle we'll see if it works
ok so amazingly this worked the macaroni
went through the pipe right down there
and now it is clear well this is my real
life right now all the windows are
blacked out
I am parked outside of a little America
Travel Center I'm here alone and I'm
just gonna watch Netflix I just made my
bed I think I'm gonna head out to the
coast after that back to Big Sur
Oh Cumberland down
[Music]
they should still be around
you know they said I have my first
breakdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in Napa California about to enjoy a nice
little snack cutter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm just a little life update I know
a lot has been happening life's been a
little crazy for all of us I would
imagine it's been especially interesting
trying to navigate it while living on
the road full-time libraries are closed
coffee shops don't wanna have indoor
seating gyms are closed which is where I
shower so that's a little challenging
and toilet paper is gone I am currently
in Reno Nevada I came out here two weeks
ago to work with the Reno Tahoe Tourism
Board so I've been photographing and
exploring this beautiful area and then
literally to the day a house it popped
up in Reno for one month so I have a
place to stay and hunker down and social
isolates social distance myself and I'm
watching after a really cute cat and a
horse which I'm pretty excited for
whatever you guys are I hope you're
staying safe I hope you're staying
healthy and keeping up the good vibes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so obviously this is my man I've been an
organ for about six weeks now and I have
not been living on the road I decided
that it was just the best thing for me
to do gyms for clothes campgrounds or
clothes I didn't have a lot of options
for showering unless I showered at a
truck stop
which would mean I need to be kind of
based near a truck stop and some of the
BLM land and National Forest was closing
so sleeping options were a little grey I
just decided that with everything going
on the easiest thing to do the thing
that made the most sense was to rent an
air B&B so this air B&B ends at the end
of May and I don't know if I'll end up
extending it as of now I'm not planning
to I'm planning to get back out on the
road as soon as I can but in the
meantime I've been hanging out here and
I have to say like I didn't realize just
how much I benefit from routine I have
been living out of a vehicle for the
past two years now so having a place to
wake up and you know like have a routine
go for a run take a shower make coffee
in the same place and sit at a desk like
those are all fresh concepts for me
right now
and I'm really just loving it in
addition to that I've just been working
on a few small projects with the van so
one of the great things about living in
an actual house with an actual address I
can have things shipped here which is
also amazing because normally receiving
shipments is very complicated so I've
been ordering just a few small things
off Amazon to better organize the van
and I'll show you how I made a little
built-in closet on the back of my seat
so this is my hanging closet and it
isn't anything crazy but I fit so many
clothes here and it's nice because they
don't get too wrinkly so what I did is I
just took a wooden hanger and removed
the hook up here and then these are
little shower curtain hooks they just
come undone and then snap back together
so yeah that's my newest little project
that makes tons of space and then back
here I use a bungee and I have a soft
case for this new addition and new
travel guitar I'm Martin with a strap
because I was having trouble playing
with the smaller one that didn't have a
strap but yeah this this guy is going to
live right back here and I just strap it
in and then I also got a plant for the
van he doesn't have a name yet but I
like him it's QT another little project
I'm working on these are the cubes that
are up in the cabinets and I've just
rolled all of my pieces so I can fit so
much more and then I found these
my clothing except for my jackets oh
yeah nothing too crazy but right now I'm
just passing the time with editing
crossing my fingers that the parks will
open again soon and learning guitar so I
will catch you guys in the next video
and I hope you're all staying safe from
doing well and yeah see you next time